HILLS: Ah, we've got a wonderful crowd here.
Welcome, one and all.
I'm Carla Hills, and I co-chair the Council
on Foreign Relations, and I feel very privileged
today to introduce our outstanding guest.
And I know you've been told to turn off your
cellphones and so forth, so I'll go in and
just tell you some few facts about Governor
Lael Brainard, who became a member of the
Board of Governors of the Federal Reserve
System in June of 2014, and her term will
end in January of 2026.
For four years, prior to her appointment to
the board, she served as an undersecretary
at the U.S. Department of Treasury and as
counsel to the secretary of the treasury.
And in those roles, she was the U.S. representative
to the G-20 financial deputies, and to the
G-7 financial deputies, and was a member of
the Financial Stability Board.
She was awarded the Alexander Hamilton Award
for her splendid service.
And she also served as deputy national economic
advisor and deputy assistant to President
Clinton, and was his personal representative
at both the G-7 and the G-8.
And prior to her government service, she served
as vice president and as founding director
of the Global Economic and Development Program
at Brookings Institution, where she built
a research program to address global economic
challenges.
In the 1990s, before she came to Washington,
she was assistant and associate professor
of applied economics at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology, and she published
a number of articles and edited a number of
books that were extremely well-received.
She earned her Bachelor's from Wesleyan University,
and her Master's and her doctorate from Harvard
University in economics, and she was a White
House fellow.
So it gives me great pleasure to give this
very special guest of ours the podium.
And so, Lael Brainard, please.
(Applause.)
BRAINARD: Well, I want to thank Ambassador
Hills for that very kind introduction, and
it's a real pleasure to be here today at the
Council on Foreign Relations.
In recent months, financial conditions have
eased, and there are encouraging signs that
domestic consumption has regained momentum.
But today's tentative signs of labor markets
slowing remind us that we cannot take the
resilience of our recovery for granted.
In today's circumstances, prudent risk management
implies we should wait for additional data
to provide confidence that domestic activity
has rebounded, and reassurance that near-term
international events will not derail progress
toward our goals.
As we consider the appropriate posture of
policy, the most immediate question facing
us is whether the data provide confidence
that domestic economic activity has strengthened
notably following two disappointing quarters.
Today's labor market report is sobering, and
suggests that the labor market has slowed.
Nonfarm payroll employment increased at an
average monthly pace of 116,000 over the last
three months, well below the 220,000 per month
average pace over the preceding 12 months.
Although the unemployment rate moved lower,
to 4.7 percent, involuntary part-time employment
increased and labor force participation declined.
The recent news on inflation, the second leg
of our dual mandate, has also been mixed.
The price of oil has rebounded significantly
from the lows reached earlier in the year
on expectations that supply and demand are
likely to be in closer alignment.
The dollar has receded a bit on net from its
peak in January, though it's still about 15
percent above the level in mid-2014 in real
effective terms.
As a result, non-oil import prices look likely
to stabilize this quarter after a year and
a half of declines.
These developments coincided with the easing
of financial conditions since mid-February.
Thus the conditions supporting further progress
on inflation are likely due at least in part
to expectations of more gradual U.S. monetary
policy, and could diminish if those expectations
were to materially shift.
While there are thus signs that inflation
will move higher over the medium term, measures
of core inflation have yet to convincingly
exceed the low levels that have prevailed
over much of the recovery.
The 12-month change in core PCE prices was
only 1.6 percent in April, which is roughly
equal to the average change from the end of
2019 to-from the end of 2009 to the end of
2014, which is noticeably below our target
of 2 percent.
We can't rule out that this stubbornly low
inflation may be having an effect also on
inflation expectations.
Market-based measures of inflation compensation
remain extremely low, with the five-year,
five-year forward currently around 1.5 percent,
which is 1 1/4 percentage points below levels
prevailing prior to mid-2014.
In addition, some survey-based measures, such
as the Michigan Consumer Survey, also remain
below historical norms.
So, in short, although some developments point
to a possible firming inflation, the persistently
low level of inflation, together with signs
of a deterioration in inflation expectations,
suggests that the risks are weighted to the
downside.
Further progress towards our goals, which
are full employment and 2 percent inflation,
will depend importantly, therefore, on a rebound
in growth.
Following disappointing GDP growth that averaged
only 1.1 percent over the past two quarters,
I've been very focused on incoming data, especially
on consumption, which points to a pickup in
growth this quarter.
Consumer expenditures rose strongly at 0.6
percent in April, and auto sales edged higher
in May.
Nonetheless, the data relevant for gauging
second-quarter growth are still relatively
sparse.
In general, demand growth in recent quarters
has benefited from relatively strong households
who are buoyed by strong employment, reduced
oil prices, and low interest rates, but have
been pulled down by weak business investment
and exports.
While consumption and housing investment more
than accounts for the 2 percent increase in
GDP over the past four quarters, business
investment and net exports together subtracted
on net 1/4 percentage point.
Of course, the rise in the dollar and the
decline in foreign growth reduced demand for
American exports, as well as profits and investment
at U.S. firms, along with the declines in
the price of oil.
So, if we look at the 12 months ending in
April, manufacturing output increased only
0.4 percent, while total industrial production
fell 1.1 percent, which, of course, also includes
drilling of and extraction of oil and gas.
Of course, if the easing in financial conditions
since mid-February, and the firming of oil
prices, and the stabilization of the dollar
were to continue, business investment and
exporters would benefit.
Of course, there are risks to the projection
that future GDP growth will be strong enough
to deliver further progress on inflation and
employment.
Most immediately, there is material uncertainty
surrounding the United Kingdom's June 23rd
Brexit referendum.
The IMF has noted that a vote in favor of
Brexit could unsettle financial markets and
create a period of uncertainty while the relationship
between the U.K. and EU is renegotiated.
Although it is very difficult to forecast
the economic effects, we can't rule out a
significant adverse reaction in the near term,
such as a substantial jump in financial risk
premiums.
Because international financial markets are
tightly linked, an adverse reaction in European
financial markets could affect U.S. financial
markets and, of course, through them economic
activity here.
We also cannot dismiss the possible reemergence
of risk surrounding China and emerging markets
more broadly.
In recent months, capital outflows in China
have moderated as the dollar has stabilized
and pressures on China's exchange rate have
eased.
Should pressures through the exchange-rate
channel reemerge, we can't rule out a recurrence
of financial stress, which could affect not
only China but, again, other emerging markets
that are linked by China via supply chains
or commodity exports, and ultimately to conditions
here.
China's making a challenging transition from
export- to domestic demand-led growth, and
the cost of reallocating resources from excess
capacity sectors to more dynamic sectors could
further impair growth in the near term.
While China has taken steps to limit the extent
of the slowdown, there's an evident tension
in policy between reform and stimulus, and
the effect of the stimulus may already be
waning.
Vulnerabilities, such as excess capacity,
elevated corporate debt, and risks in the
shadow banking sector, appear to be building
and could pose continued risks over the medium
term.
The broader fragility of the global economic
environment is unlikely to resolve anytime
soon.
Growth in the advanced economies remains dependent
on extraordinary unconventional monetary policy
accommodation, while conventional policy continues
to be constrained by the zero lower bound.
Conventional policy's efficacy is more tested
and better understood than unconventional
policy, and it can respond readily to any
upside surprises, but presently constrained
in adjusting to downside surprises.
This asymmetry in the ability of policy effectively
skews risks to the outlook to the downside,
and may amplify the sensitivity of the exchange
rate.
The evidence suggests that over the past year
dollar exchange-rate movements have become
considerably more sensitive in response to
monetary policy surprises than they were previously.
That's also consistent with recent research
which suggests that cross-border financial
transmission is likely to be amplified at
near-zero interest rates, where the ability
to provide additional support through domestic
channels is limited.
In this environment, markets have become quite
sensitive to the possibility of a prolonged
period of low growth, low inflation, and economic
underperformance, as we can see in the current
negative term premium for the 10-year Treasury
note, or the difference between the yield
on the 10-year Treasury and expected risk-free
short rates over the next 10 years.
That is a big change from the period prior
to the Great Recession.
So, as we look across these conditions, while
the easing in conditions, in financial conditions
in particular, since mid-February is very
welcome, it's important to recognize that
some of the conditions underlying recent bouts
of turmoil largely remain in place, and an
important reason for the fading of this turbulence
was the expectation of more gradual U.S. monetary
policy.
Should an event trigger renewed fears about
global growth or a reassessment of the policy
reaction function here in the United States,
financial stress could well return.
Recognizing that the data we have on hand
for the second quarter is quite mixed and
still limited, and there's important near-term
uncertainty, there would appear to be an advantage
to waiting until developments provide greater
confidence.
Prudent risk management would suggest the
risks from waiting until the totality of the
data provides greater confidence in a rebound
in domestic activity, and there's greater
certainty regarding the Brexit vote, seem
lower than the risks associated with moving
ahead of those developments.
That's especially true since the feedback
loop through exchange rate and financial market
channels appears to be elevated.
In light of this amplified feedback loop,
when conditions are appropriate for a policy
move, it'll be important that it be understood
that any subsequent moves would be conditioned
on still further evidence confirming continued
progress towards our objectives, and not as
inevitable steps on a preset course.
Indeed, the appropriate path to return monetary
policy to a neutral stance could turn out
to be quite shallow and gradual in the medium
term because it increasingly appears likely
that the medium-term neutral rate, or the
real federal funds rate that would be consistent
with the economy remaining at full employment
and 2 percent inflation, may be quite low.
Earlier in the recovery, it seemed likely
that the low level of the natural rate was
largely due to temporary or cyclical factors,
such as tight credit, weak consumer confidence,
and the loss in household wealth from the
crisis.
However, the recovery is now well into its
seventh full year, credit in most markets
is widely available, while consumer confidence
and household net worth are at high levels.
As a result, it now appears more likely that
much of the decline in the neutral rate is
likely to prove persistent, consistent with
a variety of estimates.
With productivity running very low, substantial
overcapacity and disinflationary pressures
abroad, and less favorable demographics, the
medium-term neutral rate may be lower than
previously anticipated.
And this may mean that today's federal funds
rate is closer to neutral than previously
expected.
Of course, one likely explanation for the
persistence of the low neutral rate is the
sharp drop-off in potential growth since the
Great Recession.
So if you look at the period from '53 to 2003,
potential output growth varied between 3 and
4 1/2 percent, with one very brief exception.
Over the recovery, it's averaged only 1 1/4
percent.
One contributor to this decline has been a
reduction in the labor force participation
rate due to aging, but another has been a
marked slowing in productivity growth.
Over the six years from the end of 2009 to
the end of 2015, productivity grew only a
little over 1/2 percent per year, compared
with average growth of 2 1/4 percent over
the 50 years prior to the Great Recession.
The reasons for such a dramatic slowing are
still not clear.
So, in summary, recent economic developments
have been mixed, and important downside risks
remain.
In this environment, prudent risk management
suggests there's a benefit to waiting for
additional data to provide confidence that
domestic activity has rebounded strongly,
and reassurance that near-term international
events will not derail progress.
In addition, because the depressed level of
the neutral rate of interest is likely to
reflect forces that are persistent, the appropriate
path of policy is likely to remain quite shallow
for several years.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
HILLS: Well, that was a wonderful presentation,
and you raised a lot of questions that I want
to ask you.
And I'm going to start by taking a few minutes
to talk about some of the issues, and then
turn it over to all of you to come up with
questions.
And let me start with saying talk a little
bit about how you factor in exchange rates
into policy recommendations.
BRAINARD: So the international environment
has been extremely salient over the last really
now two years in particular.
The United States economy is tightly linked
to the rest of the world, obviously through
trade, but also through financial linkages.
And some of that transmission takes place
through changes in the exchange rate.
What we've seen since the middle of 2014 is
a very significant increase in the U.S. dollar
exchange rate, in part reflecting expectations
that conditions would warrant a bigger divergence
in policy between the United States and some
of our foreign partners.
But, of course, that change in the exchange
rate, that tightening in financial conditions,
then affects our exporters, it affects our
import prices, which affects core inflation
here.
And so it, in turn, has a bit of a depressing
effect on U.S. economic activity, which front-runs
in some respects U.S. monetary policy.
HILLS: I was reading that an economist, Dr.
Bill Cline, calculates that a 10 percent appreciation
of the dollar worsens the U.S. account-current
account position by about 1.7 percent, and
the trade-weighted average of the dollar has
appreciated 25 percent in the last three years
alone.
How do you see the current account deficit
as a factor in the Fed's thinking?
BRAINARD: Well, we definitely do see that
net exports have been a drag on the economy
since June of 2014 when we started to see
that expectation of policy diversion showing
up in a sharp appreciation of the dollar.
And so, you know, you see that in a way that
is particularly evident in manufacturing,
but you see it in net exports more generally
that continue to be a drag today if you look
at the data.
And of course, that is part of the reason
that we have to be very, very careful in protecting
and preserving the progress we are making
here at home because in the United States,
while consumption makes up a very large portion
of the overall aggregate growth, it's not
strong enough really to carry the burden of
global growth in a world where globally aggregate
demand is quite weak.
HILLS: You know, you mentioned in your remarks,
I would paraphrase them by saying take it
step by step, and yet some economists are
arguing quite vehemently that we should raise
interest rates lest we create a bubble and
the problem of tomorrow.
Give some information about how we would respond
to those economists.
BRAINARD: So I think if you look across the
set of economic conditions that we take into
account as we assess what the appropriate
stance of monetary policy is, you know, we
have very specific goals of full employment
and 2 percent inflation.
And while we've made considerable progress
on the employment leg of our mandate as we've
seen from today's, even on the labor market
we've seen some slowing in recent months.
And of course, on the inflation leg of our
mandate we are still and have been persistently
short of our 2 percent target.
So under those circumstances and given the
very weak overall aggregate demand globally,
the appropriate path of policy has been to
continue to be very supportive of demand growth
here in the U.S.
Looking forward, again, you know, as I see
it, this is my take on it, current circumstances
would dictate a risk management approach.
There are important risks in the international
environment, most immediately Brexit, but
there are also risks associated with China
and the broader emerging market complex.
And there's also a fairly incomplete and mixed
picture to give us a sense of how strong the
second quarter is.
In that context, I think prudence suggests
that the risks of waiting are lower than the
risks of moving ahead preemptively.
HILLS: You mentioned Brexit and China, and
then Europe is slow.
Give me some good news that makes you think
that-(laughter) -that the future could be
brighter.
BRAINARD: So American consumers are still
relatively confident.
Their incomes have been improving.
And you know, the consumer confidence indicators
are still relatively positive.
So that is a very important bright spot that
we want to carefully support and protect.
And again, you know, we have seen an important
material easing in financial conditions that
are more supportive, likely to be more supportive
of our manufacturers and our exporters and
of business investment than certainly conditions
were earlier in this year.
HILLS: And you mentioned that, you know, the
jobs report today, 38,000 was a disappointment.
The U.S. banks reported their first quarter
and they're down 1.9 percent.
Is that also something that causes you concern?
BRAINARD: So we in taking into account the
sort of strength of likely business investment
and the business sector, corporate earnings
are very important.
And obviously there has been some evidence
that both the relatively elevated level of
the exchange rate or the more elevated relative
to what it was in 2014 on top of the very
sharp decline in energy prices that we had
seen together have depressed corporate earnings.
And that is a very important indicator for
business investment going forward.
And you know, business investment is important,
not just for growth, but also for productivity.
And I mentioned earlier that the numbers there,
you know, are puzzlingly and disappointingly
very low.
HILLS: You know, there are vacancies on the
board of the Fed.
And is that a concern?
BRAINARD: It would be great if we were at
full strength of seven rather than being at
five, absolutely, that would be very, very
welcome.
HILLS: And explain a little bit about you've
got 12 regional Federal Reserve boards.
Talk a little bit about their role and how
they fit into your responsibilities dealing
with inflation and employment, looking at
those as-
BRAINARD: Yeah.
So the way that the Federal Reserve system
is set up, the Federal Open Markets Committee,
which is the committee that meets periodically
to adjust and assess monetary policy, includes
12 regional presidents and should include
seven board members here in Washington.
And you know, the 12 board presidents are
supposed to and do bring their own independent
assessment of economic conditions.
Probably when the Federal Reserve was created
and, you know, people had to travel across
the country from the 12th district more slowly
than they do today and data was not as widely
available on national conditions, they probably
were very focused on their own districts,
which was critically important for assessing
the overall U.S. economy.
Today they bring really important information
from their districts, but we all look at the
same data.
And so the Fed deliberations, I think, is
a very rich set of deliberations among the
board members, who each have their own assessments
as well, and the presidents, led by the chair.
HILLS: Well, you can see that we're very fortunate
to have the governor where she is today.
And we're certainly fortunate to have her
on the podium, so let me turn it over to you
to ask questions.
And I would ask you to state your name and
state your question.
Q: Thank you for being here.
Rosita Najmi.
I'm on the Financial Services for the Poor
Team at the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation.
I was really curious about if at all, if it's
on the radar, of the issue of de-risking.
So we've been looking really closely at cross-border
flows, so ranging from remittances, correspondent
banking, humanitarian aid and trade finance
as well, and the kind of unintended consequences
on the poor when these flows are being cut
off or when the cost of capital is raised.
I was just curious, you know, we've been collecting
stories.
Some central banks in certain markets are
actually considering filling in the role of
the correspondent relations for the respondent
banks.
We're also seeing some banks figuring out
what the willingness to pay is to maintain
correspondent relations.
Any thoughts in terms of what the role could
be for the Fed?
Or any other just high-level thoughts on this
issue on how we could be supportive would
be helpful.
BRAINARD: So on the question of how banks
can continue to maintain their international
correspondent banking relationships while
also fulfilling their obligations under BSA/AML
and doing so very fully is an important issue
for us.
We obviously do want to see those international
relationships being able to provide the necessary
financial services to allow people to send
remittances back home or do a host of business
kinds of transactions.
And so it's an area that we have had conversations
with some of the banks that we supervise,
but also we're in close communication with
the Treasury Department that sets some of
those rules.
And you know, our hope is that the environment
will, you know, become a more sort of supportive
environment going forward.
I think banks can do what they need to do
for BSA/AML and still maintain those relationships.
And I think there's also some developments
in the technology space, the technology arena
that holds some promise of making those linkages
perhaps cheaper, more real-time, and also
safe.
HILLS: Yes, up front here.
Q: Hi.
Jon Colby from The Carlyle Group.
It's been reported that the five largest technology
companies in the U.S., for example, are sitting
on $500 billion of cash on their balance sheets.
What does that look like to you from your
perspective and historically?
And then what do you think it's going to take
to have some of that come unstuck and increase
productivity?
BRAINARD: So this question of how much different
kinds of firms, you know, have incentives
to put their cash and their capital to work
I think is one that's extremely important
for the strength of business investment, for
growth more generally.
And that's on the short-term part of the ledger,
and then, of course, medium to long term for
the productive potential of the U.S. economy.
So it's certainly an area that we have a lot
of interest in.
In terms of the tools that we have, obviously,
you know, we've been very supportive, I think,
in terms of the stance of monetary policy
has been supportive of activity in the business
sector, activity in the household sector.
There are other policy considerations that
may be relevant that just are well outside
of our realm or our influence.
But certainly this issue of business investment
is an important one, and trying to create
the best possible environment for that investment
to take place is really where we come into
that equation.
HILLS: Yes, third table back.
Q: Bill Courtney, RAND Corporation.
The eurozone and Japan appear to be over-relying
on monetary policy and under-relying on structural
economic reform.
Is that risky?
And are there any prospects that the eurozone
and Japan will gather the political will to
undertake more structural economic reform?
BRAINARD: Well, I think obviously we have
a common interest, the United States, Japan,
euro area, larger markets, China, in seeing
a broad set of policies in each economic area
that supports global aggregate demand more
broadly.
And you know, in each economy, that would
entail a somewhat different mix of fiscal
and monetary policies as well as structural
policies.
And those are very specific to the circumstances
of the different economies.
You know, I do think that in today's circumstances
where aggregate demand overall in the world
seems to be quite weak and deficient, there
is a case for greater fiscal support in some
economies, so places like the euro area potentially.
Certainly, we've seen some moves in that direction
in Japan to complement monetary policy.
And also, you know, there's plenty of potential
for infrastructure investment and productive
investment that not only would boost short-term
demand, but also would boost the long-term
supply potential in many economies around
the world.
So you know, the mix is an important issue.
It's going to be specific to each economy,
but our interest is to see that, you know,
everybody's pulling in the same direction
to try to lift aggregate demand.
There's really no good outcome where policies
are just shifting demand across borders.
That's, in the end, going to be self-defeating.
HILLS: Yes, right here.
Q: Hi, I'm Teresa-
HILLS: Wait for the mic.
Q: Sorry.
Teresa Barger from Cartica Capital.
So I'm just wondering if you all look at the
ratio of inventory to sales, and it's been
going up very steadily the last 18 months
and now reached almost the peak of the 2008
spike, and whether that's of concern and whether
you see that as a recessionary signal or not.
BRAINARD: So the board has incredible economists
who know more about every data series, U.S.
and foreign, than one could ever ask.
And inventories is a critically important
focus of, you know, the forecasting staff
at the board, and is a very important input
into our assessment of, you know, if you see
weakness in the first quarter or the fourth
quarter.
How much of that is going to be remediated
by a rebound in the first quarter is importantly
associated with this question of whether inventory
build was high or low relative to what one
would have expected in our usual forecasts.
So it is an area of intense focus.
I don't think that I would say that it's a,
you know, a clean predictor.
I think there are very few kind of individual,
clean predictors of, you know, whether the
economy is strengthening or going into a recession.
But it is extremely important to try to understand
when we do see some weak quarters, like we
have, to try to assess whether there may be
some very important temporary factors that
are going to abate in the following quarter.
And you know, again, more broadly, I think
we've seen some data on the second quarter,
but I think it would be extremely important
to have additional data to make a full assessment
of what the second quarter is going to look
like.
HILLS: Over here, yeah.
Q: Hi.
Nelson Cunningham of McClarty Associates.
Good to see you, Governor Brainard.
It's been said in recent years that corporate
profits were at an all-time post-war high
as a percentage of GDP, whereas employee compensation
was at a post-war low as a percentage of GDP.
Are those measures in the same place today?
And how do you view what has been higher than
historically normal corporate profits and
lower than historically normal employee compensation?
BRAINARD: So in fact, interestingly we have
started to see a bit of an upturn in the labor
share.
And as you pointed out, the labor share had
fallen to historically very low levels.
And we're only seeing the beginnings of tentative
signs of an upturn there.
But obviously, you know, there's good news
potentially for households and for the domestic
consumer, potentially good news from a distributive
point of view given what we've seen in terms
of distributive trends over a very substantial
period of time.
But there, I think, is too little of a, you
know, sort of trend in this direction so far
to really make, you know, very firm conclusions
about what we've seen so far.
HILLS: Way in the back of the room.
Q: Thank you.
Howard Schneider with Reuters.
Lael, I was really taken with your discussion
of the neutral rate.
You're suggesting that the rest of the world
has kind of imposed an effective cap on how
far the Fed might be able to go if in fact
the world is what's dragging the neutral rate
down.
And what I'm wondering is, what happens on
day two when you all wake up and realize that
2 percent is about as good as you can get?
Is that when you start having the discussion
of a higher inflation target or some sort
of hybridized policy where you'd include other
things other than the interest rate, even
though you're off zero?
BRAINARD: So I think right now it's a tentative
kind of observation, but it does appear that
what we have seen in the estimates to be a
historically very low neutral rate and which
I think many had assumed was attributable
primarily to cyclical headwinds, it now seems,
both in some of the estimates, but also just
by watching the evolution of the economy,
that that neutral rate may well be low, historically
low for some time to come.
And if that's true, it does mean that we are
closer to neutral today than we thought we
were or that many people might have thought
we were, which in turn could mean that the
path of policy, the appropriate path of policy
is likely to be more gradual, more shallow
over a somewhat longer period of time.
Now, that's attributable to a host of things.
And some of that may indeed reflect international
factors.
It also likely reflects some factors here,
like the aging of our own workforce.
And as I said earlier, too early to tell,
but productivity, low productivity, could
also be a piece of that puzzle.
In terms of what does it mean for policy,
I think what seems to me to be the sort of
most clear-cut observation is that we're going
to want to engage in a fairly cautious approach,
a risk management approach, and move cautiously
assessing the effect of any further moves
as we go, rather than being tied to some preset
course that might be derived from some previous
tightened cycle that took place under very
different circumstances.
HILLS: Yes, right here in the middle.
Q: Hi.
Nancy Jacklin.
Hi, Lael.
This is sort of going back to something that
Carla asked you earlier, which is not just
do you see any good news, but you talk about
balancing risks.
And you gave us a pretty good brief on the
downside risks.
The question is, do you see any upside risks?
And in looking at that are you considering
any issues in the financial sector, including
some signs we see of things in the real estate
market now, like house flipping, search for
yield that's leading to people buying loans
from the peer-to-peer lending that may have
no credit process attached to them, issues
relating to the amount of derivatives that
the SEC is seeing being used in retail mutual
funds?
What are you seeing as if you're looking at
balancing risks, are there upside risks that
you worry about?
BRAINARD: So it is certainly a huge focus
of our work at the board, is to carefully,
systemically, periodically assess risks that
might be building in the financial sector.
And you know, we have a much more well-developed
analytic framework, and a staff that is now
dedicated to this in the wake of the crisis.
And we have additional tools that are macro-prudential
in nature that complement our monetary policy
tools so that, to the extent we do see building
risks in certain sectors, we have a broader
set of tools that would allow us to, at least
in part, preemptively, ideally, address some
of those risks, without overly burdening monetary
policy, which already has pretty clear dual
objectives.
With regard to the assessment of risks today,
you know, earlier we had called out some concerns
about leveraged lending and put out some guidance
there.
And we saw some dissipation and some correction
in that, to some degree.
I think more recently we have taken a look
at CRE and particularly concentrations of
CRE in some bank balance sheets as a potential
risk.
In terms of the real estate market, you know,
there it's hard to generalize, because these
are-to some degree the developments there
are very specific to different regions.
But we are very focused.
There's some signs of a very, you know, extended,
subprime auto set of lending.
But not to an extent that you would see it
as a macro risk at this point.
But we are very, very focused on the potential
for risks to build up in particular financial
sectors, and then to pose risks more broadly.
And you know, we're much more systematic about
assessing those risks and trying to connect
those risks to tools that we have at our disposal
to address them.
HILLS: Yes, in the back of the room, in the
center.
Q: I'm Haik Gugarats with Argus Media.
How concerned are you about the asymmetric
effects from the rise of price of oil, in
the sense that it may nullify some of the
gains in consumer spending we've seen in the
past year, without boosting business investment
because producers don't seem to be drilling
more as a result?
BRAINARD: Yeah.
So I would say that I can't give you a very
precise answer to that question.
I mean, as oil prices declined, you know,
I would say our previous historical experiences
and the kind of macro estimates that you get
from those didn't prove to be very good guides.
We probably got more of a response in terms
of the very sharp deceleration of investment
in drilling and mining, for instance, than
we had seen in previous historical episodes.
And it's hard to tell because these consumers
respond over time, but it also seems that
consumers didn't respond as much as one might
have predicted based on older macro estimates.
And similarly, just as I don't feel that the
historically rooted estimates were particularly
accurate in thinking about the period in which
the oil price was declining, similarly now
that we've seen a bit of an increase there
and a bit of a stabilization, I don't have
a huge amount of confidence in how that is
going to show up in, you know, consumers responding
to higher prices at the pump and therefore,
you know, seeing a little bit of a moderation
on the consumption side, versus providing
more incentives for producers to go back and-certainly
go back and start investing in exploration
and trying to expand capacity.
I think it would be very hard to generalize.
The other thing that's very important is that
our oil and gas sector has changed dramatically
since some of those earlier estimates were
put in place.
And so, again, what the price point is, I
don't think we have precise estimates.
But certainly it's a very important driver,
and we're looking at it very closely.
HILLS: Further questions?
Yes, over at this table, right in front of
the mic.
Q: Thank you.
Governor Brainard, Rod von Lipsey, UBS.
The question that I have just goes to your
sense in the Fed being data driven, but the
economy and the markets being somewhat sentiment
driven, is there a possibility that we could
have a sentiment-driven recession or trend?
BRAINARD: So a part of the data we look at
relates to sentiment.
(Laughter.)
And you know, again.
So if we look at some of the consumer-the
most recent consumer sentiment indicators,
they actually look pretty resilient, which
is reassuring.
But you know, there's different lags in terms
of how people respond to changes and their
perceptions.
And so, you know, we don't really know going
forward whether consumers are going to continue
to feel buoyant and continue to see the kinds
of consumption numbers that we saw in April
carrying through further into the second quarter,
which of course is very important factor in
driving U.S. growth.
But it is I think just an argument for being
a little bit patient in terms of reading more
signals on the economy, not just on actual
spending but also on how both consumers and
businesses are feeling about spending an investment.
I think it just goes in the same direction,
which is that we want to have greater confidence
that growth rebound is really in place before
making a policy judgement.
HILLS: This table in the middle.
Yes.
Q: Thank you very much Sherry Stephenson,
International Centre for Trade and Sustainable
Development, Geneva.
I want to go back to the discussion on productivity.
To me, that really seems to be a very, very
significant concern.
The 1/2 percentage growth in productivity
that we've had since 2009 just isn't enough
to have a very dynamic longer-term growth
prospect.
And yet, you've stated that we don't know
the reasons behind this slowdown.
So if we don't know the reasons, how can we
effectively address it, I mean, other than
saying we need more business investment?
And maybe that isn't an issue the Fed works
on, but could you comment on this and what
you think?
People say the IT-the spurt from the IT revolution
has now run its course and we don't have another
big, you know, positive stimulus in sight.
And that's of definite concern.
So how do you boost long-term growth in the
absence of productivity gains?
BRAINARD: So I-there are a bunch of reasons
that people are pointing to as possible explanations.
And you know, I don't think any of them are
definitively-you know, in terms of the evidence-are
definitively known to be the answer.
And one of the reasons that's out there, as
you suggest, is that somehow the earlier investments
that had been made in information technology
have now been fully diffused and run their
course.
Others are looking at the question of measurement
error, that we had some good work at the Fed
which looks at this question of whether it's
possible that we're just not capturing some
of those productivity gains because of the
way that we measure, services in particular.
But of course, the question there is whether
that same measurement error wouldn't be equally
applicable to earlier episodes with a lot
of IT.
And so not clear.
There are other questions or explanations,
that it takes a while for potentially productivity-enhancing
investments to diffuse.
So if you looked at artificial intelligence
today, or maybe robotics, or genetics, that
maybe these are things that are quite promising,
but really haven't been diffused to any great
degree.
And so, you know, maybe we will see a pickup.
I don't know the answer.
I don't have a strong view one way or another.
But it is obviously so critically important
in terms of driving potential that we need
to understand it.
And investment is a big piece of it.
Education is an important piece.
Having a very vibrant environment for innovation
not only to take place, but then to diffuse
through investment is extremely important.
So, you know, it is something that is very
important to our work.
But again, you know, our tools in this area
are limited to the ones that try to create
a-not create, but support a productive environment
for investment.
HILLS: Yes, in the back.
Way in the back.
Q: Thank you.
Jang Zhen (ph), Voice of America.
Just wonder, what's the China factor in the
Fed's decision?
Because there's talk about this rumor on Bloomberg
News, and talking about the S&ED, Strategic
and Economic Dialogue, which is being held
in Beijing.
It said the officials in Beijing would just
ask the U.S. officials about the Fed interest
rate hike issue, but Central Bank in China
denied it.
But do you think that China-the Chinese economy
might be a factor?
What do you think about this?
Thanks.
BRAINARD: So what I can say is that in assessing
the appropriate stance of monetary policy
for the U.S., you know, we have a very clear
objective function that is established in
law by Congress, which is domestic focused-full
employment and price stability, which has
been interpreted as 2 percent inflation.
So that's our focus.
And then, of course, because we are so tightly
integrated into the world-you know, the dollar
is viewed as a reserve currency, we have some
of the most liquid, deepest financial markets
in the world-but of course we're also tightly
linked on the trade side.
How our policy path and expectations of our
policy path are then affecting financial conditions,
and of course importantly through exchange
rate channels, does, through a very important
feedback loop, come back around and affect
U.S. domestic conditions.
So in the past year, I would say, China has
figured prominently in terms of global risks
and global financial conditions, as China
has managed challenges on its domestic front.
And so those kinds of considerations naturally
have to be taken into account when we think
about risks to the outlook.
And they naturally will affect policy deliberations,
and potentially the path of policy.
And so that is the way in which risks emanating
from China-and of course, you know, China
was the really predominate source of global
investment growth for several years following
the recovery.
And that was a very important source of demand
and growth for emerging markets that were
linked to China, both through commodity exports
as well as through supply chains.
So we've seen that kind of as China's attempting
to rebalance its growth path-rely less on
investment, less on resource-intensive, export-oriented
sectors, more on domestic demand-that has
rippled through supply chains in other emerging
markets, and very importantly through commodity
markets.
And so those things do matter for our domestic
objectives back here in the U.S.
HILLS: All right, question here.
Q: Irving Williamson, U.S. International Trade
Commission.
You touched on fiscal policy in Europe and
in Asia.
I was wondering if you might want to touch
on fiscal policy in the U.S., and how that
might be complicating your efforts, particularly
in regards to the question Mr. Cunningham
raise about income inequality in the U.S.,
achieving full employment when you see the
number of people dropping out of the wage-the
labor force increasing.
Thank you.
BRAINARD: So in the U.S., and we are differently
situated than many of our foreign partners
in the sense that we have been recovering
and, you know, we have made quite a lot of
progress on the employment leg of our mandate.
You know, the labor market has come a long
way although, again, we've seen some signs
of slowing in the last few months.
A little bit less progress, but nonetheless,
you know, we've also seen core inflation around
1.6 percent, which is below our objective.
But we are seeing progress.
And so we are differently situated relative
to some of the other economies, particularly
Japan and the euro area.
Nonetheless, you know, in a period where in
particular, you know, it may be that the neutral
rate is low for some period of time, and a
period where, you know, there are reasons
to want to both support aggregate demand in
the short run, and also the productive potential
of the economy and productivity in the longer
run, there may be a case to be made, for instance,
for infrastructure investment complementing
the goals that we're trying to achieve in
monetary policy.
But again, you know, those questions about
really needing to bolster aggregate demand
are even more important in other parts of
the world where they have a bigger challenge.
HILLS: Well, I'm afraid we've run out of time.
But I hope you'll join me in thanking Dr.
Brainard for not only a wonderful presentation,
but also the most comprehensive responses
to a great variety of questions.
So thank you so much for taking your time
to be with us.
(Applause.)
(END)